so one thing that's interesting being in
Europe so I live for those of you that
don't know I do live in England um and
I'm an American I'm from Chicago and I
moved to England and I've lived in
England I was recruited to play
volleyball I started the podcast things
just kind of took off so being here the
interesting thing is that you get to see
a lot of differences culturally you know
London is such a diverse place my Lord
it is like the most diverse place I've
ever lived like you can talk to people
from Spain you can talk to people from
Italy Nigeria Pakistan like London has a
it is truly a Melting Pot okay and
coming here I I have to say I I heard a
lot of things about women in other
countries being very different um where
you're not going to find this Western
mentality and I have to be honest guys I
was a bit disappointed um I actually
found that women that came from Spain
Italy Africa once they got to the UK a
lot of them developed the same mindset
you know I I've interviewed men that
dated women from Poland and were screwed
over in divorce court that dated women
from Africa and were screwed over in
divorce court that really like if they
come to the West it's kind of the same
thing but you know one country that I've
heard that the women are more modest and
feminine and better wives in is Japan
now I did I did have one girl um from
Japan on my team and she she was nice
but I don't I don't remember anything in
particular that different I guess but
um it's interesting to see Americans
going to Japan and talking about their
experience so there's one article that I
remember I read a couple of weeks ago of
a woman going to Japan and talking about
how the men just found her to be
invisible she went there and she's like
I haven't been on a date in 3
years yeah they're not they're not with
this and I think it's because you know
the men there maybe don't tolerate
it they don't they're not with that
in Japan and here's a clip of a woman
talking about some of the cultural
differences being an American moving to
Japan if you are coming to Japan and
planning on going to the gym let me just
warn you do not wear a matching set do
not wear a cute little outfit like this
I know that we all love them I feel so
super cute right now but if I wear
something like this to the gym Japanese
people literally treat me like I have
written on my forehead like they
stop and they look at me and they're
like what the like I've forgotten
to get dressed this is how I dress now
now that I've been living here for a
year when I go to the gym this is how I
dress like all the other Japanese people
I'm not kidding you this is the
vibe this is the vibe okay the pants
with the leggings on underneath this is
the look that we go for okay I couldn't
feel less hot I couldn't feel less like
working out than in this but if I wear
the other thing then people literally
stop what they're doing and look at me
so this is the vibe so if you come to
Japan just be prepared
yep no it's so true because even the
first outfit I'm like that's almost
modest in 2023 you see these chicks in
like nothing you know and and even me
like I grew up playing volleyball so
what are you wear in volleyball you wear
Spandex and I I was thinking about how
weird that is how they literally put
like 10 11 12 year old chicks in Span
isn't it is that kind of weird I was
thinking about this um but you're so
used to it as a volleyball player you
don't even think much of it but you know
in Japan modesty is encouraged
femininity is encouraged the one thing I
don't understand about Japan though is
their their birth rate is so low so it'd
be interesting I wish I could talk to
some people that are actually like from
Japan that could tell me like why the
birth rate is so low there because
they're they're they're um they really
do have an aging like an aging
population